Allyson I'm gonna start with you because
this movie started with you you're
discovering a book I want to ask you
about the first time that you read this
book and why you thought it was
something that you had to attach herself
to and try to get made for seven years
well I was producing an independent film
called teri that aza Jacobs directed and
it was we had adapted a short story also
written by Patrick DeWitt some from some
unpublished work and we had a great time
doing that adaptation and he wrote the
screenplay and we shot that movie and
John ended up being in the movie and he
was wonderful and at the end of that
process
aza the director said to me you know
there's a Patrick just finished his
second novel and there's a part in it
that I think would be great for John so
through some maneuvering I was able to
get that manuscript it was this thick
and read it before it was published and
I just remember you know staying up all
night my heart was racing I think I
finished it as the Sun was coming up and
I I just knew it was that good and so we
were John and I were fortunate through
this relationship we had just
established with Patrick to option it
before it was was published which was
key because then it went on to be you
know shortlisted for a Man Booker and it
won all these awards and we would have
never been able to get it otherwise I
don't think but then as the profile of
the book Rose the in our project sort of
changed to you know we started to get
calls from Hollywood and we realized we
had to really focus and figure out how
we were gonna make this movie and make
it you know just make it the best
possible version of itself it could be
yeah having the rights to this book
before was published felt like like
getting the secret to the formula for
the gold in the river or before the
Commodore you know cuz we knew we knew
once that formula was published in the
paper they'd come looking for us at what
point does Jacques become part of the
conversation sorry at what point did a
couple of good ideas in my life and this
was one of them but I you know I've just
been a giant fan of jacque's work I
think John and I saw read my lips in the
theater near here actually in 2001 and
we're just blown away and then I've sort
of been tracking with all of his films
and we were starting to think about who
would really be best at the helm of this
material I kept thinking of jacque's
work is it so it's so you know greedy
and muscular and tough in a way but yet
there's this there is also a delicacy
there's this emotional undercurrent
that's so beautiful and you kind of have
to work for it as an audience to you you
have to you know ask for a certain level
of engagement I think there's always a
giant payoff when that happens as well
so I was just I you know it just seemed
like the right mix and John of course
was on board and so we Jacque was at
Toronto with rest and bone
you just done resting bone and we flew
to meet him and Tomas was there and I'll
let John describe that meeting so it was
okay and at some point we have to let
Jack talk you all the way from France to
be no we we dog was not done badly to
hear him talk that dog wasn't a little
more like when you talk about me well we
went to Toronto and we had never met
Jack and yeah he was there for rust and
bone and we we were we you know Allison
has produced many movies before and but
this was my first time and so it was our
first time as a pair trying to pull this
off and in the beginning we felt like
you know so like kids dress up an
adult's clothes like yeah we're going to
meet with a world-famous director now
and show him this property we have we
felt really you know out of her league
and so we had dinner the night before
this meeting in Toronto we found this
great little French restaurant we're
like this is perfect for the vibe in
here this is
we have to come here tomorrow for lunch
and so we asked the owner to the
restaurant can we make a reservation
please for tomorrow for lunch and oh no
we're not open for lunch we're never
open for lunch and then you know we
followed up the next day with a pathetic
phone call and and he opened the
restaurant for us and so it was just
these three people from France these
three people from America sitting down
like a mafia they taunt and we slid this
book across the table like a pile of
money you know I think Jacques was
suspicious at first you know beware of
strangers bearing gifts but they could
did he feel fit I was terrified of
course maybe depends on the sector how
many calories many things about American
actors and a valet to talk about like it
was true Tomas I'm gonna ask you about
your about the adaptation because warm
and Morris are not major characters in
the novel and they become a major part
of the story what were the conversations
about elevating their role in the film
and why was that important do books
countries he wants to translate now no
it was we needed something that the book
is marvelous it was really seduced us
immediately but it's it's written in the
first person really it's read the story
of Alliance a lot of inner monologues
and and the inner thoughts of Eli
discovering the world so we needed in
order to keep the tension that it that
we we need in the film we needed to
develop the other another couple so
actually it's read the story of two
couples and I ended up being that so
that there will be tension and it really
were the rhythm of the film will be the
rhythm of the chase we needed that and
where other things that that we had to
add it to it like the the Utopia the
idea that warm as that that adds another
layer to the story it's not just the
gold for the gold it's the gold because
there's a plan there's an idea behind it
and it becomes then an idealist now and
we don't spend old movie talking about
money or the gold we we think we talk
about an ID so
that thing that I think that added in
another layer also to the to the to the
story so what were your conversations
with your cinematographer been Wadi Bay
about the color and about where the
camera could go because we don't sip
typically see a camera go underwater in
a film in the 1850s no sit here like a
may han joon-soo sex a domenica pom acid
with putin satanic cult
co2 encode can western appeared to us
that it was as much a fairy tale as it
is a western new no 12 FF on cetera
still and we do shots on our main
reference was night of the hunter the
commode for Melman family commercial
confetti correspond sorry Fox add a
photo to [ __ ] test on what he blonde
contrast in Gnome stream Lee contrast
black and white zebra dead in certain
facade the color of the coat they could
have tetra for try contrast it that you
look for very strong colors colors that
would be like in the fairy tales image
you don't affect you poke around opieop
a book kudos to the separate trem on a
cooler there's not that many DP that
work with many colors and the posotive
aqui favicon Monique evinces a fresco
suppress go beholding of the work he
does with I'm an Armani Kareem it's a
very baroque John at what point does
Joaquin become part of the story how
does that happen and how much time do
you have as actors to talk about this
material either before you start filming
or while you're on set talking about
materia with Joaquin is tough
well first of all I should point out
that you know we when we hitched our
wagon to Jacques
it became Jack's film at that point you
know like the book is one thing and then
Jaques expression of the book is is
another and so we were really keen to
have that quality to the film because we
knew like that's how good movies are
made they're not made by hiring a
director the way you would hire an actor
or something so loved Jack had total
freedom to do whatever he wanted with
this movie with the one caveat that I
could be in it even though I was hoping
to play that character I had to be like
but you know whatever I'm easy to be the
shopkeeper her so when it came down to
casting the other roles you know jakka
of course is a great collaborator you
know but he has the final say so he
would you sort of pull people what do
you think about this what do you think
about this and he asked me like well who
would you see as your brother once I
started to imagine who could be my
brother and who who I could really care
for that much and be that connected to
Joaquin just be it had to be him I
didn't say that to Shaq of course
because I had to let it be Jack's
decision and I was just fingers crossed
it's like they're having a phone call
today you know like and then he offered
it to him on the phone my first phone
call like wow okay good Rothberg good
start and that said when Joaquin and I
started to work together I realized I
even though I'd met him a couple times
through Paul Anderson um I really didn't
know him at all
at all it was hard for us to even make
eye contact at first and I'm pretty
adaptable with people you know it just
it was just too intense for us or
something so anyway to go back to my
first joke you don't really talk about
material fuckiní you just kind of you
just kind of show up and you and you
spend as much time together as possible
and that's what we that's what we did we
rode horses and we shot guns and we'd
walk around and sub
Spain where a ton of westerns have been
shot by the way in al meriya where we
began that town there was built by
Sergio Leone literally and so yeah so we
would walk for hours and hours around al
meriya in silence for the most part
because I just realized like if I try to
reach if I ask this guy to you know come
towards me he's gonna run the other way
like and that's what we quickly realized
he's such an instinctual actor that if
you make a suggestion his first instinct
to me be like yeah let's not do that you
know and he taught me some valuable
things as an actor or have you reminded
me of some valuable things as an actor
you know I started out I started out in
the theater in Chicago and following
your instincts and being in the moment
it's like the heart of improvisation and
that's what I that's where I really
learned how to be an actor was through
improvisation classes and so the whole
thing is like improv is like not coming
up with kind of a plan beforehand and
then maybe it'll happen improv is like
going in blind like with nothing and and
wacky and a couple times you know
sometimes iMovie sets you get nervous
you know like I at least I do anyway and
I'm one of these people like he wants to
say the thing right I'm mad at you in
this scene right and and it's and it
probably comes from insecurity or fear
you want some affirmation from the other
actor to say yeah of course I'm mad at
you about the thing and then yeah duh
okay let's go do the scene like but
Joaquin was like don't don't [ __ ] do
that I'm sorry I was just yeah I know
what you're doing it because you're
insecure does a guy know not [ __ ] you
like we would have these crazy brotherly
conversations by the end of it we're
really like fully Elie and Charlie we're
living together and cooking dinner for
each other every night and driving to
and from work together like
shoulder-to-shoulder all weekend so it
made me realize like you know what
other actors doing is none of your
business and that what I'm doing some of
his business in fact we started to work
with Jacques in a way where Jack would
go and talk to him and then he would go
and talk to me because I think Joaquin
just found it so embarrassing to be
directed and from someone else because
then if I knew Chaka asked him to like
pick up the pace and this or that and
then he didn't do it I would have failed
you know he or he would think I failed
in my eyes or something anyway it was a
real interesting journey John Allison
Jacques Tomas thank you so much for
bringing your films les